what's up guys and welcome to Horizonte
Jinna where we discussed the latest tech
news and DA Virginia's tech products so
recently the asus strix GT X 1080 was
actually offered for five hundred and
sixty nine dollars on superb is now
unfortunately that deal is currently
over but that is the lowest of that card
has been this whole entire year there's
actually doesn't deal on super bridge
for that same exact card for ten dollars
more at $579 so if you guys are watching
this video and would like to pick that
up
then make sure to click the link in the
description below as soon as possible so
obviously these cards are finally
dropping under MSRP but should you take
this opportunity to buy a card but
before we go into that make sure hit
that subscribe button if you guys would
like to stay updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs so
before we discuss if you should buy a
graphics card right now we should
understand why GPU prices are even
dropping in the first place so if you
guys didn't already know if tyrion is
just not doing that well right now for
example it dropped from over $1,400 to
less than $400 in just a couple of
months and if diem is one of the most
popular things to mine with GPUs and as
a result if what you're trying to mine
is not doing well then there's not going
to be a lot of people entering the mine
scene and there's not gonna be a lot of
people expanding either and so the
demand for GPUs from these miners has
been significantly reduced because of
the significant drop in value of
aetherium on top of this the difficulty
- - theorem has become much harder in
just the last four months alone the
difficulty has increased by one and a
half times and as a result that's
definitely deterring many people from
continuing to buy GPUs for mining
finally there's also a new ASIC from a
company named bit me that's supposed to
perform much superior to GPUs in
interior mining this ASIC is
specifically designed to my aetherium
and it is supposed to produce 650 mega
hash the second while only consuming 750
watts to put this in perspective a gtx
1080 TI which is fully overclocked and
at
100% Parliament can only do about 37
mega hashes but it consumes 343 watts so
as you guys can see the ASIC miner
consumes about twice as much power but
it performs twenty times better than the
GTX 1080p I as a result it's much more
efficient and its price should also be
much better than what the GTX 1080p I
can offer plays it specifically built
for mining so the performance per dollar
should be much better but the miners who
are completely focused on just a theory
of mining may just jump onto a 6-figure
it's just so much more profitable and as
a result the anticipation for such a
minor coming out very soon has also
greatly reduced many miners from going
out and buying GPUs they're simply
waiting to see if it's worth buying one
of those or just continue with your GPU
setup so they have right now overall you
still can't make money out of
cryptocurrency mining but it is just not
a quick way to make a buck anymore and
there isn't that much hype around er
either and as a result there's much less
demand from GPU miners for a game or
graphics cards and as a result if
there's less demand the price is gonna
go down on top of this the demand from
gamers for graphics cards has also been
lowered significantly by now the people
who really wanted graphics cards just
ended up paying the higher prices or
ended up buying used GPU so as a result
most miners and a lot of gamers have
been taken out of the equation as a
result I would say that the high demand
that there was for graphics cards has
subsided finally the only problems left
is stock and RAM prices Nvidia has been
telling us that they have been
addressing stock hershey's for a couple
of months now so I think that can be
taken out of the equation as well so the
only thing left is Ram prices however I
don't really think Ram prices affected
the GPU market very much at this point
Ram prices have been inflated for about
a year since about last May and they
have increasing throughout last summer
and the fall
but the GPU market wasn't really
affected NVIDIA GPUs pretty much
maintain MSRP and they're often lower
than MSRP
throughout last summer and the fall on
top of this rare prices peaked in the
fall
and despite that GPU prices were still
not that effective foreign media at
least so as a result I don't think Ram
prices affected GPU prices too
dramatically
overall GP prices have been dropping
because of less demand higher stock and
RAM prices subsiding finally and this is
why we were able to find GTX 10 eighties
for less than MSRP and this is not just
true for GTX 10 80s for example you can
get GTX 10 60s for $300 right now and
you can get G takes 10 70s for about
four hundred and seven dollars and gtx
1050 t is for about one hundred and
eighty dollars so as you guys can see
they're all only about fifty to a
hundred dollars inflated as opposed to
the two hundred three hundred dollars
before due to all this MBA GPUs are
probably going to hit MSRP very soon but
should you take advantage of this and
buy a GPU well in my opinion the next
series of GPUs from Nvidia is just
around the corner and I really think
that you guys should consider waiting
for these new GPUs instead of buying a
graphics card right now recently there
was actually a massive leak about the
performance of the GTX 1180 now these
are leaks so take everything with a
grain of salt but anyways now what these
leaks were suggesting is that the gtx
1180 had performance numbers that were
very close to the titan XP now the gtx
1180 is also supposed to have the newer
hardware like gdb are six memory and as
a result according to sleek the gtx 1180
said about match if not exceed the
performance of the titan XP furthermore
this leak is suggesting that the gtx
1180 will be offered for $700 just like
the founders edition 1080 card and this
card suppose come out in July so it's
just around a corner and may definitely
be worth waiting for because just for a
hundred lists more than what you are
willing to spend for a GTX 1080 right
now you can pretty much get a Titan XP
so what about for lower level cards I've
said this many times but I strongly
believe that the best place that we can
look for the performance of the newer
cards is actually by looking at past
there's no gaps like for example last
generation the 1070 was just slightly
better than 980ti and as a result this
generation I believe that the 1170 will
be in the ballpark of the 1080 Ti on top
of this the 1170 should be coming out at
around the same time as the 1180 and it
should be in a price range of the high
300s so as a result all you guys are
concerned to buy a 1070 right now if we
just wait for two more months you may be
able to pick up 1170 for a cheaper price
but get the performance of a GTX 1080i
so just keep that in mind before you
purchase a gtx 1070 any time soon now
next for the 1160 and here I still think
there's going to be a huge performance
upgrade last generation the 1060 was
pretty much equal with the 980 and so
the fifth generation the 1160 should
probably perform around the 1080 and the
price should be around like 250 dollars
so as a result the price and into
performance I would say sound good for
the 1160 but the only problem is that
the 1160 isn't expected until the end of
this year so it's really quite a long
wait so if you guys really don't need an
upgrade then obviously you guys should
wait but otherwise I guess it doesn't
really make sense for that one something
else to keep in mind is that there's
going to be a huge price drop
once these new graphics cards come out
so even if you don't want a new graphics
card let's say you want a 10-6 - right
now you may be able to for the 1070 once
the new 1170 and 1180 come out because
10 serious graphics cárcel I'll be
outdated by then and their prices will
drop so overall by waiting for the next
year's of graphics cards you may be able
to save money on a graphics card
courtesy right now or even afford next
level graphics card overall my opinion
everyone who is not in dire need of an
upgrade should definitely consider
waiting because you may be able to
afford a next level of 10 Series card
afford a new 11 Series card or simply
just save a bit of money but that just
my take on it make sure to push what you
guys think in the comments down below
also many of you guys have been waiting
for many many months at this point so
you might as well wait
a little bit more and make it all worth
the wait so what do you guys think do
you guys think it's completely worth
waiting for graphics cards or are you
like I don't care and I really just want
a graphics card for a reasonable price
make sure to push what you guys think in
the comments down below because I do
read all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video then make sure to drop a like
and hit that subscribe button if you
guys would like to see more videos just
like this every single day but until
next time bye
[Music]